Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d', Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Today's Maestro Hook,...
...the Maestro Hook is a small conversation piece that you can use with foreigners...
...to get a good conversation going.
Today is about presents.
In America, when you get a present, you open it in front of the person.
If it's food, you even eat it.
Of course in Japan, when you get a present, you don't open it and you take it home,...
...and you open it later, and thank them later.
There's a little bit of difference there.
For example, when you get a present in America,...
..."Oh, thank you!"
"Can I open it?"
"Oh! This is food. I'm gonna try it."
"Oh! It's very good. Thank you!"
Okay, today's Maestro Menu...
It's nothing special.
Oh, it's nothing special.
Oh! You shouldn't have.
Okay. Next, Maestro Lines.
"I got you something."
"Oh, really? Thank you!"
"Oh, no, no. It's nothing special."
"Oh! You shouldn't have. I'm so sorry, thank you!"
"Oh! Please enjoy it."
Okay, that's it for today.
And we'll see you again next week on AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
See you later!